hey snapchat so right now I'm in this
what is this called again this is the
light stage a light stage to get my face
3d capture it's like perfect
[Music]
hey guys I'm Justine and I'm here at
Activision's capture studio and I am
really excited to announce a really fun
contest but you guys can actually win a
chance to come here to Los Angeles take
a tour of the studio with me you'll also
get to be motion-captured just like the
characters in the college of the game
hey Justine everybody I'm the producer
here at the activision capture studio
we're gonna walk you through all the
various stages we take with our
technology to bring character to life
are you ready I'm ready first thing
we're gonna do is take you to our
scanning equipment we're going to scan
in you're like this what is this the
most advanced we've got over 6,000 LEDs
in here thousand LEDs what I'm gonna
take a selfie best lip selfie ever I'm
like actually scared for some reason 3 2
1 clamp your eyes shut and pucker your
lips I feel really pretty what's
happening this is so awesome I'm so
excited for something to actually come
here and be able to do this with me
because I want to do it again so this
rotates around so it's a lot like
getting an x-ray I was just gonna say I
feel like I'm with a dentist and I
didn't floss this morning so I'm gonna
yell that this could be you and not only
that you actually get a 3d printed model
and take home put this on your shelf
show it to your mom
now that we've captured your likeness
we're gonna capture your action before
we do that though we got to put you in a
suit what's so special about these suits
we are incredibly dependent on velcro to
attach all of these stylish markers to
you oh that's great
you look at oh yeah it's very
fashion-forward I think she's really
gonna catch on
should we put one on my phone just in
case yeah if you want to track it
absolutely now that you're suited up and
ready to go it's time to get down on the
mocap volume call it duties now but
introduce you guys to Danny who's gonna
be our stunt double since one of you
guys haven't actually won yet but this
could be such an amazing experience I
promise you guys you're gonna have the
best time and not only is it gonna be
such a fun time this for an amazing
cause every anti supports the Call of
Duty endowment which helps unemployed
veterans get back to work so I look
forward to seeing you guys out here in
Los Angeles
I'm gonna go giggle one more dance
[Music]
do you guys have like a big velcro wall
but people come up we were just talking
about that I just wanna like jump just
stick